اعلنت حركه النهضه ايداع نائب رئيس الحركه
ورئيس الحكومه الاسبق علي العريض السجن في
مطار في قضيه التسفير الى بؤر التوتر خطوه
قال جبهه الخلاص المعارضه انها غير
قانونيه وتاديف للتغطيه على خيبه الرئيس
قيس سعيد في الانتخابات التشريعيه في
الاسنان قالت حدو شغل ان توقيتها وان
الوضع تعفا وانه سيتخذ قرارات مناسبه
لصالح البلاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذلك خبر
رئيس الحكومه الاسبق ونائب رئيس حركه
النهضه وفي اي سياط اتت
ما واجهه ربط جبهه الخلاص اعتقال معارضي
الرئيس قيس سعيد بخيبه امله في الانتخابات
التشريعيه الاخيره التي لقد اقبالا ضعيفا
كما اظهرتها نسبه المشاركه فيها
واي فرص للخروج من الازمه بالنظر الى
الكيفيه التي سيستقبل بها الرئيس سعيد
رسائل الداخل للحوار الجندي ورسائل الخارج
التي تدعوه الى الانخراط في عمليه اكثر
شمولا لتوسيع نطاق المشاركه السياسيه
[موسيقى]
تتسارع وتيره الاحداث في تونس العاصمه
ملامحه اكثر استقطابا لازمه السياسيه
لم تمر الساعه قليله على اعلان نتائج
الانتخابات التشريعيه التي جرت وفق
الدستوري ومراسيم الرئيس قيس سعيد
مظهره نسبه اقبال هي الاضعف في تاريخ تونس
قبل وبعد الثوره حتى جرى اعتقال رئيس
الحكومه الاسبق ونائب رئيس حركه النهضه
مفتقده لاي اساس قانوني وقالت ان الهدف
منها التغطيه على ما وصفته بنزع نتائج
الانتخابات كل شرعيه عن سعيد ومنظومته
انتقادات رد عليها الرئيس سعيد باشد منها
مؤكدا ان نسبه الاقبال تعرف بعد الدوره
الثانيه للانتخابات وليس قبلها فيما قالت
اتحاد الشغل انه لن يقف مكتوف الايدي اذا
الوضع الذي وصفه بالمتعفل
حركه النهضه اكدت ان الزنجبي قاده الحركه
في السجن في قضيه التسفير وغيرها يراد منه
الضغط على السياسيين الرافدين لما وصفته
بالانقلاب
واضافت الحركه وان استضافه المعارضين
محاوله للتغطيه على الفشل
ولن يحسن من معيشه التونسيين
جبت الخلاص المعارضه للرئيس قيس سعيد
طالبت باطلاق سراحل رئيس الحكومه الاسبق
علي العريض وشدد رئيس الجبهه احمد نجيب
الشابي على غياب اي مبررات قانونيه
لاحتجاز العريض وقال ان سببه هو الخيبه
التي اصابت رئيس الجمهوريه بعد النتائج
الانتخابات البرلماني
سبب ليس قانون السبب في الخيبه التي
اصابت السيد رئيس الجمهوريه بمناسبه
انتخابات يوم 17 يوم 17 ديسمبر الشعب
التونسي ادارى له ظهره وقال له انا غير
معني بمسارك سياسي وهمي ليس همك همي
الخروج من الازمه الاجتماعيه
فبتالي
لصرف النظر على هذه الخيبه الكبرى واللي
تصحبها عزل دوليه كبرى لصرف الانذار عن
هذه الحقيقه من قبل على شخصيه الاولى من
الحياه السياسيه التونسيه بش الناس تنسى
شويه ما وقع يوم السبت
تتولى ردود الفعل بشان الانتخابات
التشريعيه التي لم تتجاوز نسبه المشاركه
فيها 11 بالمئه بحسب هيئه الانتخابات فقد
اكد الرئيس قيس سعيد خلال لقائه مع رئيسه
الحكومه انما وصفها ببعض الجهات المعروفه
لم تجد هذه المره شيئا تركز عليه سوى نسبه
المشاركه في الدوره الاولى من الانتخابات
التشريعيه للتشكيك في تمثيليه مجلس نواب
المقبل في حين ان نسبه المشاركه لا تقاس
بالدور الاول فقط بل بالدورتين حسب تعبيره
في المقابل اعتبرت احزاب وهيئات معارضه ان
نسبه المشاركه تمثل نهايه لشرعيه الرئيس
بشكل كامل ودعت الى اجراء انتخابات رئاسيه
مبكرا
الى ذلك ده علامين العام لاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل نور الدين الطنبوبي دعا
رئاسه الجمهوريه الى حوار جدي مسؤول لا
حوار مخاتله
باكد ان الرسائل الشعب التونسي للمنظومه
السياسيه واضحه لكن لا احد فهم الرساله
مشددا على ان شعب سيجسد ارادته من خلال
النظام المنظم والمقطر وابقى تعديره وخلى
الطبوبي ان التوقيت انتهى وان الوضع تعفن
مضيفا ان الاتحاد لا يتخلى عن دوره الوطني
وانه سيتخذ القرارات المناسبه من اجل
الوطن بعد الاجتماع القادم للهيئه
الاداريه
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى رضا بالحاجه
القيادي في جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
ما سر هذا التوقيت مباشره بعد الانتخابات
التشريعيه التي لم تشهد اقبالا
يعني كبيرا بل ضعيف جدا
ما بين تاريخ الانتخابات التشريعيه ونسبه
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه وبين
ايقاف السيد علي العريض يعلم الجميع ان تم
قضيه منشوره ان عدد كبير من المتهمين في
هذه القضيه ان هذه قضيه شهدت اطوارا
متعدده للبحث وان تاريخ البحث في هذه
القضيه مع السيد علي العريض محدد سلفا
ويبدو ان قاضي التحقيق اتخذ قراره
باستمرار البحث في هذه القضيه مع الاحتفاظ
بالسيد علي العريض الان ان نحمل المساله
اكبر من حجمها وان يحمل المساله ما لا
تحتمل ويقع الربط بين نتائج الانتخابات
الهزيله او دعنا نقل مباشره الكارثيه و
ايقاف السيد علي العريض اعتقد ان الامر لن
يكون مصيبا في اغلب حالاته ثمه مصارا
قضائيه فما تمصار تحقيق يتعلق به لكن هل
انت مقتنع ان الموضوع صدفه
هل انت مقتنع ان الموضوع صدفه لا
الامر ليس صدفه انا قلت ان البحث في هذه
القضيه وتاريخ البحث في هذه القضيه محدد
سلفا قبل التعرف عن نتائج الانتخابات
التشريعيه وقبل التعرف عن نسبه المشاركه
ولا ادري من الوجاه في الربط بين ايقاف
علي العريض في قضيه منشوره بالقضاء ومحل
بحث لدى القضاء والسيد علي الى ريض على
اقل مستوي يتحملوا مسؤوليه سياسيه لا يمكن
نكرانها والبحث يتعلق بالمسؤوليه الجنائيه
فقط لا تصور ان تم تعبت مقبول بين ايقاف
هذه العريض وبين نتائج الانتخابات
التشريعيه ما العلاقه بين الاثنين خاصه
ويعلم الجميع انه الى حد هذه اللحظه ثمه
مواجهه كبرى بين الرئيس قيس سعيد وبين جسم
القضائي وانه ورقم كل ما قام به الرئيس
قيس سعيد لم يتمكن من احكام قبضته على
القضاء حتى يسير هذا القضاء كما يريد وحتى
ينفذ هذا القضاء جمله من الايقافات او غير
ذلك ليخدم من مصلحه الرئيس
سيد رضا بالحاج ما العلاقه
واين
واجهت الرابط بين اعتقال علي العريض
والنتائج الانتخابات او المشاركه في هذه
الانتخابات التي جاءت هزيله كما قال ضيفنا
شكرا هذا الايقاف ياتي في سياق انهيار
المسار الانتخابي الذي وضعه قيس سعيد
بانعدام المشاركه او المشاركه الرمزيه
وبالتالي عقاب قيس سعيد في مساره وياتي في
مسار ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه ال- اا تتبع
وملاحقه همم السيد علي العريض جاءت في
اطار تتبع سياسيين ومعارضين لقيس سعيد
بدات بالعميد عبد الرزاق الكيلاني
بغاز الشويشي بغيرهم من النواب الذين قام
بتتبعهم امام القضاء العسكري والقضاء
العدلي القضيه المتعلقه
بالعريض هي قضيه كيديه نابعه من شكايه
كيديه وفيها توظيف للقضاء وفابريكا وفبركه
للملف الاستاذ علي العريض همم وقع التحقيق
بقى هو همم البارحه الثالث مره وكل مره
ياتي ويقوم بالتحقيق ويعود الى منزله
البارحه كان استعداد واضح لايقاف همم علي
العريض رغم ان شروط الايقاف التحفظي لا
تتوفر في في الملف وفي حاله علي العريض
رغم ذلك قام بايقافه القاضي التحقيق
تطبيقا لتعليمات وللصرف النظر على الازمه
والانهيار الذي يعيشه قيس سعيد ومصاره
الانقلابي لصرف النظر
وتوجيه الراي العام الذي اليوم حديثه
الوحيد هو انهيار قيس سعيد عزله قيس عائله
الداخليه والخارجيه فقيس سعيد ومن خلاله
وزيره العدل ارادت صرف النظر عن هذا
الموضوع الهام واا كان يظن ان الراي العام
سيهتم بموضوعك علي العريض فوقع عكس ذلك
اليوم جميع الاعلام جميع
السياسيين لا يتحدثون الا على انهيار
المسار الانتخابي الذي رسامه قيس سعيد
واصبح في عزله همم سيد اليحياوي
المسار القضائي المستمر يعني توقيفات ثم
الافراج ثم توقيفات وافراج وياتي موضوع
على العريض ايضا في هذا السياق يعني لماذا
لا تصل كل هذه القضايا الى نتائج حتى
القضايا التي سبق ان همم تحدث عنها الرئيس
بنفسه محاولات اغتيال
الطرد المشبوه وغير ذلك كل هذه الامور
تنتهي بانتهاء الحديث عنها من دون اي
توقيف ومن دون اي قرائن فعليه او حقيقيه
لماذا
نعم هو في الحقيقه يعني الامر يعود الى
طبيعه الجسم القضائي تونسي وتربيعه كلفه
التقاضي في تونس الكلفه على المستوى
المادي ولكن ايضا على المستوى الزمني هي
على ملجميع ان الكثير من القضايا والتي هي
على قدر شديد من الاهميه تاهت طوينا في
اروقه القضاء لمده تزيد عن ثمان سنوات
وهذا الامر مستمر منذ ما قبل الخامس
والعشرين من هجريا وما بعد الخامس
والعشرين من اشبيليه الان هل ان الاسباب
كما يقول البعض هو تراكم الملفات او تشابك
الملفات او طبيعه البحث والتحقيق او صعوبه
الوصول الى قرار نهائي في ما يتعلق بجمله
من القضايا ولكن من المعلوم سلفا ان كلفه
التقاضي في تونس خاصه على المستوى الزمني
هي كلفه عاليه جدا والقضايا تبقى طويلا
وطويلا في ارويقه المحاكم حتى القضايا
البسيطه منها ولسنا نتحدث عن قضايا الراي
العام مثلا كاغتيال الشهيدين شكري بالعيد
ومحمد ابراهيم وايضا على قضيه تسخير
الشباب يعني المساله معلومه
ما الذي تقوله في هذا السياق يعني همم فقط
يعني تونس ليست استثناء كل الدول
المسار القضائي ياخذ وقتا لكن على الاقل
تكون هناك همم في النهايه قرائن وادله
وموقفين وغير ذلك لكي تستمر القضايا وهذا
ما لم يحصل في تونس لذل تنسى القضايا كان
اعلاميا او حتى قضائيا هل هذا منطقي
لا انا اخبركم كيف يكون الامر في تونس
وخصوصيه التقاضي في تونس وتحدثت عن الكلفه
الزمنيه بمعنى ان الزمن الذي يتطلبه
حلقضايا ما يدوم طويلا يدومني سنوات طويله
وهذه الكون عندما تحدث عن قضيه تسفير
الشباب الى بؤر التوتر نحن نتحدث عن قضيه
راي عام نتحدث عن متهمين متعددين نتحدث عن
جهات متعدده هذه القضيه فيها حتى امنيين
مورطين والسيد علي رعيد بصفته اساسا كوزير
الداخليه قبل ان يكون رئيسا للحكومه متهم
في هذا القضيه واذا من الطبيعي ان تطول
هذه القضيه وان تاخذ الوقت اللازم في في
الاخير لكي نتمكن
القضاء البحث لانه هذا مبحث طويل يعني
ويمكن النقاش بشكل كبير وفقا للمعطيات
والادله التي يجب ان تتوفر ولم تظهر لكن
يبقى السؤال ااا التزامن المتعلق بنسبه
المشاركه الهزيله في الانتخابات كما كما
انت همم وصفتها طيب الاء الاء همم تعني
ذلك هذه المشاركه الا تعني رساله قويه
للرئيس قيس سعيد بان مساره لم يعد مقبولا
من الشارع بالمطلق وهذا ما ترجمته صناديق
الاقتراع
نعم الرساله الاساسيه التي وجهها
التونسيون من خلال صناديق الاقتراع ان
الاوليبيه بالنسبه اليهم ليست اولويه
سياسيه وانما الاولويه هي اولويه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه او في الحقيقه تضافرت الكثير من
العوامل حتى سجلنا نسبه المشاركه الكارثيه
في هذه الانتخابات وليست مجرد نسبه مشاركه
هزيله
بالملاحظه ايضا ان السيم الاساسيه في كل
المحطات الانتخابيه كانت سنه العزوف عن
الانتخاب حتى اصبح في تونس ثم التسميه
للاغلبيه الصامته والاغلبيه الذين لا
يشاركون في العمليه الانتخابيه
باختصار يعني موضوع
التنازل الارقام في كل محطه انتخابيه لا
ينتفق على هذه المحطه عندما تتحدث عن
ثمانيه في المئه ثم ترتفع بقدره قادر الى
11% يعني هذا الموضوع همم لا يمكن ادراجه
في نفس السياق
ساعود اليك في هذه النقطه تحديدا السيد
اليحياوي لكن انت ذكرت نقطه مهمه اود ان
اطرحها على السيد رضا الحاج ليس بالضروره
ان ذلك كان بفعل مقاطعه المعارضه سيد رضا
بالحاج بقدر ما هي رساله من الشعب ان
الشعب التونسي لم يعد يهمه المسار السياسي
همه المسار الاقتصادي والمعيشي وهو ما
ارسله من خلال صناديق الاقتراع الفارقه ما
رايه
هو ااا فيه جزء من الحقيقه الشعب التونسي
الذي صدق يوم 25 جويليه عام عمليه التحيل
التي قام بها قيس سعيد من خلال تقديمي
وعود لتحسين ظروف العيش
وتركيز ديمقراطيه جديده تقطع مع القديمه
التي يعتبرها فاسده كل هذا لم يحقق منه
شيء الوضع زياده تدهور اليوم المواطن يحجز
عن الحصول عن لتر من الحليب او كيلو من
السكر او غيرها من من المواد الاساسيه
التي كانت متوفره منذ عقود ولم تشهد لها
تونس
المساله الان هي بين الشعب الرئيس
لا ساتيكم المعارضه لها دور كبير يوم 25
جويليه المعارضه الحقيقيه الديمقراطيه
قالت هذا انقلاب جبهه الخلاص قامت ب 20
تحرك بين اجتماعات ومسيرات في الشارع
اخرها منذ اسبوع الاف المتظاهرين نزلوا
زعماء وقاده الجبهه وغيرهم من المفكرين
قاموا بفضح العمليه هذه العمليه
الانقلابيه منذ عام ونصف اليوم بعد ان
كانت 90% يسند قيس سعيد اليوم اقل من 10%
هنالك مساهمه المعارضه هنالك مساهمه جبهه
الخلاص وغيرها من
الديمقراطيين والحقوقين وكذلك
المهم هو النتيجه بحسب رايكم سيد همم
سيد يحيى حجاوي يتلقف
الرئيس قيس سعيد هذه الرساله يعني هي
الرساله قاسيه عمليه هل
سيتلقطفها هل سيدخل في حوار جدي نحن امام
تهديد من الاتحاد التونسي للشغل بان الوضع
تعفن والتوقيت انتهى يعني كيف يتصرف
الرئيس سعيد
من الرئيس قيس سعيد انه يمضي قدما دائما
في مشروعه او في مخططه ولا يلتفت يمينا
ولا يسارا ونقطه القوه الاساسيه للرئيس
قصص سعيد هي المعارضه التي تقف في وجهها
في وجهها هذه المعارضه لا تنصت الا الى
صوتها الداخليه ولم تتلقى في رساله الشعب
انه قد مشى هذه النخبه السياسيه المعارضه
في جميع المحطات التي
تتحدث عن المعارضه
فعلت فعل شعب نفسه بالرئيس بنفس المستوى
الان ان تتحدث عن 11% باختصار
لا لا لا انا انا اردت ان نوضح لك الفكره
بان هذه المعارضه تريد ان تستثمر في سنه
العزوف عن عن عن الانتخابات في حين انها
لو كان لديها استبدال شعبيه كما تزعم لا
تمكنت هذه المعارضه في مناسبه اولى باسقاط
الدستور عبر الدفع بقواعدها للتصويت الى
وحينها كان يمكن انهاء المسار تماما
والفرصه الثانيه كانت هذه الانتخابات
التشريعيه عبر التثبيت باوراق بيضاء
ولكنها لم تكن بهذا ولا ذات لانها تدرك
ايضا انه ليس لديها امتداد في الواقعه
التونسي وليس هناك اي طرف من المعارضه
قادر على ان يمتلك مليون صوت بل 500
الرئيس يمضي قدما كما كنت منذ البدايه
سيمضي قدما في مشروعه ولم يلتفت لا يمينا
ولا يسارا وسيبقى على موقفه من رفض الحوار
مع هذه النخبه السياسيه لانه قد جربها
سابقا طيب سيد الحاج لن يلتفت حتى مع هذه
الارقام لن يلتفت الرئيس وهو ماضيما
خيارات جبهه الخلاص خيارات المعارضه هل
بامكانها همم وقف هذا المسار وهي التي
اخفقت حتى اللحظه في وقته
جبهه الخلاص اليوم تلتقي مع اطراف كثيره
90% من الطبقه السياسيه اليوم تدين مسار
قيس سعيد ليس صحيح لا يوجد ما يثبت ان
الشعب التونسي يرفض هذه المعارضه او
برنامجا في مقاومه الانقلاب لم يقع اي
انتخابات اخر انتخابات المعارضه هي الاولى
لم يقع اي استشاره شعبيه وهي قامت بمطالب
بمقاطعه الاستفتاء والاستشاره
والانتخابات وحققت نتائج المطالبه
بالمقاطعه هو عمل سياسي وبالتالي هنالك
معارضه اليوم همم اطراف المعارضه تتسع
وتنمو
اتصالات بين جميع اطراف المعارضه اليوم لم
يبقى لقيس سعيد الا حزين او حسي ليس لهما
اي تاثير او بعض المثقفين الذين همم بعد
ما راوا ان قيس سعيد دخل في مازق يريدون
اشكرك في الحقيقه يساندون قيس سعيد سيد
رضا بالحاج شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس وشكرا
بالحسن اللي يحياوي ايضا من العاصمه
التونسيه
انتهت الحلقتنا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]